[Music]
kids all over the world love paw patrol
but we got a bit worried because
sometimes it might end up teaching them
some pretty bad things make sure you
watch until the end when we'll ask why
there are so few girl pups if this is
your first time visiting the things then
hit the subscribe button and give this
video a thumbs up today we're going to
tell you about ten terrible lessons paw
Patrol shouldn't be teaching kids bad
local leadership there are many
different theories about how all levels
of government should work whether you
want an active state or a so-called
night watchman one there is an idea
about how things should run for you
however they are all largely agreed that
in times of crisis leaders need to step
up this is why we think that any
aspiring young politician needs to try
not to follow in the footsteps of
Adventure Bay's mayor goodway seriously
we aren't entirely sure how she got to
be mayor of the town and paw patrol in
the first place tends to panic at the
slightest bit of trouble which is not
good when there's a town which runs into
as many problems as Adventure Bay
secondly if there's her pet chicken
chickaletta now we have nothing against
politicians having pets former American
President Theodore Roosevelt kept a
menagerie of pets including a badger
when he was in charge of the United
States but mayor goodway's closest to
chickaletta might raise a few eyebrows
for instance she carries the bird with
her pretty much all the time which has
to be a health and safety problem and
chickaletta is also deputy mayor which
seems like an abuse of executive power
one clue to her electoral success may be
that she's the descendant of Adventure
Bay's first mayor Grover Goodway
incompetence favoritism and nepotism
aren't exactly a good way to teach kids
about responsible leadership evil cats
now we love cats they are lovely cool
smart and friendly animals this is why
we really hate it when cousin of getting
portrayed as being bad guys now while
the rivalry between dogs and cats is an
age-old animal story trope we do wish
that cats could be seen as being good or
at least not antagonistic however as
much as we love paw patrol it's another
case of what might be termed Elora
phobia fear of cats or it promotes it in
some way okay if you're a fan of paw
patrol you'll know that there is a
rivalry between Adventure Bay's mayor
goodway and foggy bottom's mayor
[ __ ] now leaving aside the fact that
while mayor humdinger is somewhat
dastardly yet rather more suited for a
mayor rowdy than mayor Goodway
there's one thing this show's creators
did that we thought wasn't so good and
that is that they made the villainous
foggy bottom version of the paw patrol a
group of cats or to be precise the
kitten catastrophe crew they are a group
of young cats who mirror what the pups
of the paw Patrol do only they do it in
a naughty and villainous kind of way
this is a shame because we think young
children really should know that cats
are really nice we're worried that paw
patrol is teaching them that they aren't
for boat skills captain Horatio turbot
better known as captain turbot is one of
the main human characters in paw Patrol
he's the marine biologist and fisherman
who is seemingly constantly getting into
some kind of scrape of some kind however
we really hate to say this but captain
turbot could and probably should sort
himself out and stop relying on the paw
patrol pups to get him out of trouble
we realized that might seem a little bit
harsh but when you take a look at things
then it's pretty much true okay here's
one great example have you noticed how
whenever he's in his boat he quite often
has a mobile phone in his hand
we shouldn't have to tell you this but
that's a pretty bad idea using your cell
phone while you're driving is illegal in
a lot of places because using it means
you aren't paying full attention and you
aren't in full control of your car so we
think the same should apply to pose we
also think that Captain turbot has a
definite tendency to fall off his boat
it seems to happen in an awful lot of
episodes rather too many in fact for
someone who's supposed to be a ship's
captain and worst of all it's pretty
rare that you see them in some kind of
lifejacket and these are all things that
are pretty bad to tell kids in one of
their favorite shows
pup pup boogie if you're as much of a
paw patrol fan as we are then you'll
know that one thing our heroic pups will
love to do when they have some downtime
is to pay a bit of pup-pup buggy that's
the dancing based video game that our
heroes can't get enough of now we love
video games but we can't help but think
that there's a mistaken message being
sent out in some form or another here
the thing is we aren't entirely sure
whether young kids the sort who watch
paw patrol should be quite so targeted
about video games
well one video game in particular now in
fairness we will also admit that there
are worse things and pup pup boogie
looks fun and it might teach people
about coordination and
do some to the joy of dancing which are
we hope you'll agree pretty good things
but still reinforces the idea that video
games are some kind of cultural be-all
and end-all which is a shame when the
song from pup-pup boogie is insanely
catchy which while not being a terrible
lesson as such doesn't help matters but
anyway we think that there's a pretty
terrible lesson for kids caught up at
pup pup boogie we are really hoping the
paw patrol does something to get kids
reading again the role of a vet one of
the things that we really love about paw
patrol is that there is a really big
cast of characters there's someone for
pretty much every occasion in Adventure
Bay and we love to see what they get up
to when we watch the show however there
is one character who's told us a bit
because we are never entirely sure what
it is that she does and that character
is Katie who is supposed to be one of
the town's vets we like Katie because
she's clever and she's kind she also has
a cat called Callie which is pretty cool
however while she is supposed to be a
veterinarian we aren't entirely sure how
she is one if that doesn't make sense
consider this it is a pretty rare
occurrence in fact we can't remember it
happening on paw patrol at all that we
see Katie actually looking after any
animals no what we do see Katie doing
instead and we see it rather a lot is
washing the animals in Adventure Bay
that need treatment this is really not
what a vet does at all we're worried paw
Patrol is telling kids exactly that well
it is important to wash and groom your
pet you really shouldn't take them to
the vet if that is all that needs to be
done with them so we think that it is a
pretty terrible lesson where our riders
parents Rider is one of the most
important characters in paw patrol we
think that it is fair to say that he is
the most important human character at
any rate this is because he is the de
facto leader of the paw patrol he is a
ten year old boy and he is the person
who leads and trains the pups to carry
out their heroic rescues we like Ryder
and we bet you do as well however
there's one question that we don't know
the answer to and if you think about it
it's a pretty bad lesson to teach young
kids and that question is where are
Ryder's parents we never see them we
never hear from them we never even hear
about them in fact it is like they don't
even exist
at least not in the here-and-now of
Adventure Bay and because of that it
might teach kids that they don't really
need their parents or at least they
don't need someone to look after them
now we know that's a really bad idea we
remember when we were little we couldn't
have cooked long without someone to look
after us at all so while we loved the
character of Ryder it would be really
good if we could hear from or at least
about his parents from time to time
Marshall should be more careful while we
love all the pups at paw patrol we will
admit that we have taken one in
particular to our hearts and that is
Marshall to Dalmatian fire pup he's
brave and he's sweet he's funny however
there is one problem that we have with
him and that is for some reason he is in
charge of the paw patrols and medical
supplies that is the thing that we
aren't too keen on because depleted
extremely bluntly Marshall is rather
clumsy with medical supplies being
incredibly precious and important it
might not be the best idea to put a pup
who has a tendency to fall over his own
feet in charge of them or at least we
think that he could be given training
this is a terrible lesson because it
might just tell kids that they shouldn't
worry about being careful with important
things and we know that is not the case
on the other hand though we know that
there is one positive lesson people can
learn from Marshall and that is the
value of loyalty we know that he is the
sort of dog that will always be there
for people so we can see how he got the
role that he did nevertheless we still
think that Marshalls clumsiness isn't
exactly the best lesson that kids could
be taught you don't have to win
everything one thing that often serves
as a catalyst in paw Patrol is some kind
of mishap that takes place during one of
Adventure Bay's many competitions there
seems to be some kind of contest from
pretty much everything you could think
of in the town so far in the series you
can take your pick from the tallest and
tastiest cake contest the cleanest town
contest the great hot-air balloon race
fastest fire pup competition The
Adventure Bay sheep herding competition
a frog jumping competition and the
annual mayor's race that is a lot of
competitions for what has to be a rather
small town now leaving aside whether
these things are publicly funded or not
which is another question for another
day we are worried that they will give
kids the wrong idea we think that it's
possible that youngsters will end up
wanting to enter every competition going
that is a problem because it could
easily lead to some kind of burnout
for instance if it
it enters more than one contest it could
lead to them not being able to do as
well as they could do if they only
entered one of them so we think that paw
Patrol needs to cut down on the contests
and tell kids that it's okay not to try
to win everything merchandise and fandom
a lot of the terrible lessons that paw
Patrol is teaching kids are things that
can be easily turned around but there is
something that is a little bit more
insidious and that is the sheer amount
of paw patrol related toys dolls games
and general paraphernalia that a fan of
the show can own even a quick look at
the Amazon website shows that there are
more than 6,000 things in the toys and
Games category alone now this does bring
up a very important point and that is
that there is an implication that the
more merchandise you owe and the more of
a fan you are and it is very important
that kids know that is not true
sure it's good have stuff related to
your favorite TV show or movie or book
series or whatever but it doesn't mean
that you're a better fan than someone
who doesn't have it they might not be
lucky enough to have this sort of money
that means they can get everything
related to a franchise or they might not
have enough space in their home so it is
kind of a shame that there are so many
types of paw patrol toys and games we
think that the creators of the show have
unleashed a kind of merchandise craze
and we don't want kids from less
affluent families to be left out where
are the girl pups we love paw patrol a
lot but there is one big thing that
bothers us and that is the lack of
female role models among the pups yes
there's Skye and in the second season of
the show there's Everest then we think
that might be a bit of a problem you see
we think that Skye is had a pretty raw
sort of deal while the other pups have a
range of gadgets that they can use Skye
who wears pink which seems kind of
stereotypical only has a pair of wings
and while Everest is pretty cool she
doesn't appear as often as we might like
her to so we would really like to see
paw patrol take a lead and show young
girls that they don't have to be
constrained and held back but they can
achieve anything they can set their mind
to and with the current gender imbalance
on the show we don't think that that is
a thing that it's doing right now which
is a shame because we think it would be
awesome if it did but we wondered
whether there were any other terrible
lessons that paw patrol shouldn't be
teaching kids what have we left out
don't be shy let us know
leave a comment that's all for our 10
terrible lessons paw patrol shouldn't be
teaching kids thanks for watching don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]